hello and welcome to spectator tv's
weekly us election special
now the spectator is expanding fast in
america and you can be part of this
success story
get 10 off a subscription by going to
spectator dot u s
forward slash subscribe and enter the
promo code tv it's not that difficult
we'll send you a stylish monthly
magazine spectators us edition
and you have full access to our website
and to all our newsletters
we'll even throw in a free whiskey
tumbler that's an offer only
for spectator tv viewers i'm afraid you
have to buy your own whiskey
now i'm delighted to be joined by
saurabh omari
the opinion editor of the new york post
uh jacob hubron the editor of national
interest
sarah elliott of republicans abroad uk
and the spectators u.s editor freddie
gray we're going to be talking
over the next hour about hunter biden
that you didn't guess that
the troubling role of big tech in this
election
on the biden case for joe biden
administration might look like and what
will happen
to the republican party after trump if
he loses
on november the third first up hunter
biden
now back in december president trump was
impeached on the grounds that he'd
abused his
power by pressuring the president of
ukraine to dig up dirt and joe
that that was the biden son hunter who
was being paid
large sums of money to sit on the board
of a ukrainian
energy company burisma despite having
no qualifications or experience in the
energy business
but because he was joe biden's son now
the impeachment attempt failed
and the story kind of died until this
week
when the new york post published emails
from a board member of burisma
thanking hunter for the introduction to
his father
then the vice president it was by any
standards a sensational story
published by america's oldest newspaper
followed more allegations
about hunter getting substantial
remuneration from chinese companies for
acting
as an intermediary to his father but big
tech
wasn't happy facebook and twitter
decided to suppress
the new york post story people who
shared the story on their social media
feeds
found themselves censored even banned
the white house press secretary kylie
mcginney
well she had her twitter account blocked
by having shared the story
twitter claimed the story was flagged
for being inaccurate
then claimed it contained personal
information
both twitter and facebook now have a lot
of egg on their face so robert murray is
with the newspaper
but ran this story surab it's a pretty
significant not just the story but the
big
tech censorship did did you see this
coming did you ever think there was a
chance that they would censor the story
thanks for having me neil
i'll be honest i work on the opinion
pages and our
manager columnists and op-ed
contributors so i had nothing to do with
the production
uh editing and uh publishing of the
story i
encountered it when we ran the paper the
following day and
like everyone else um so i can't tell
you what my
colleagues who where the editors and
journalists on the story thought or
whether they were shocked
but i would say that having observed the
way big tech works
and increasingly puts its thumb on the
scales of our democracy
given its vast power over the flow of
information
i i would say that i was not shocked
but i was shocked with by the
blatantness of it
and um the sort of uh
boldness which with which essentially
democratic operatives
working at the highest levels in these
companies boasted about
um censoring the story so it didn't
begin with twitter
it began with facebook and andy stone
who's a communications director at
facebook
sent out a tweet early in the morning
saying i won't link to that link to that
awful new york pro story
but i will say that it deserves to be
fact checked and in the meanwhile
we're going to reduce circulation now
andy stone before joining facebook
worked at senator barbara boxer's office
she was a democratic senator from
california and
for the democratic congressional
campaign committee so
here he was a former high-ranking
democratic staffer with his hands over
the levers
of the internet where free speech lives
or dies in
in our time saying yeah i don't like
that story before there had been any
dispute
about the underlying facts and bear in
mind neil there still hasn't been any
major dispute to the core facts in other
words if
biden or hunter wanted this story to go
away the easiest thing i could do was to
say
those emails aren't authentic that
laptop doesn't belong to hunter
they haven't done that and even then the
pro
the sort of scrutiny that stories are
subjected to hadn't played out
so preemptively they reduced
preemptively they they reduced
circulation of the story
and that's it's a new thing i mean
there were plenty of stories over the
past few years that were anti-trump
stories published by left-of-center
media
such as the story about michael cohen
being in prague michael cohen being so
born to perjury by the president
that that were facts that factually
collapsed
and yet they weren't banned they were
factually questionable and yet their
circulation wasn't reduced no i mean i
can see plenty of
stories social media has repeated
without doing the kind of fact check
checking they're talking about up
we still don't know for sure do we
if a meeting between this ukrainian and
uh then vice president biden took place
the though the the denial from the biden
team
was was somewhat caveated wasn't it
because it said there was no record
on his official schedule i think was
roughly the wording
uh used i'm not sure
yet have they they have not
categorically denied
that the meeting took place have they no
they
their initial statement was very
carefully worded um
uh neil you're a journalist so you know
pr people can be very meticulous with
words
they said that the story didn't take
place as
alleged by the new york post then when
politico did follow up
they just didn't rule out they said we
can't rule out
this but it was cursory
and informal okay
but it was not categorical so
the new york post says things stand at
the moment it stands by the story
there's no reason
for it in its view to withdraw
or uh qualify anything that is printed
so far
absolutely i mean we've not run a single
uh correction uh just i mean
we look forward to it being scrutinized
and we've been
extremely transparent about what we know
and what we don't know about the
provenance of the
um
the material in other words we were very
more so than let's say the trump tax
story in the times a few weeks ago
or any number of other stories that have
been released we said look
this laptop was dropped off a
uh the laptop owner
never came to pick it up nor did he pay
for the
repairman's services the repairman who
we know is a republican
looked at the material thought they were
shady contacted the fbi
but before turning over the hardware to
the fbi
he also made a copy gave that copy to
bob costello who's rudy giuliani's
lawyer we learned
about the fact of the hardware being
around
um from steve bannon
and eventually got it from rudy giuliani
and we were very clear about the fact
that we are not sure
whether it was hunter himself who
dropped it off for repair in other words
if we wanted
if we wanted to be uh taking liberties
we would have said yes it's hunter's
laptop but we didn't do that we said
it's unclear whether it was hunter who
dropped it off so
at every step we've been transparent
about how we got hold of it
um and so i and there's there's
there's been no denial or counter
factual material bought forward that
where we would retract or correct a
single
[ __ ] okay jacob hilbron
it's a great story no questions i think
it's a great story anyway
it's probably not a game changer though
is it for the election
no there there are two two aspects first
there's the washington post and nbc are
alleging
that oh contraire giuliani got wrapped
up into a russian disinformation
campaign so that's the
counter attack apparently supposedly the
fbi
has been investigating this for a while
um
either way i think the american public
has
burned out on russia
russia itself is playing no significant
role
in the campaign donald trump hoped that
the
unmasking scandal that he kept touting
would prove to be pivotal in the
election
the justice department went nowhere with
that investigation
so i don't think that there's there
might be a little smoke but i don't
think that there's a serious fire here
that has occurred and let me let me put
that to syria elliot and then i'll come
back to you jacob
that's probably a a reasonable judgment
is it not sarah
yeah i mean i don't i don't think that
this story is going is
is going to have a a lot of legs i also
think the russian
uh issue is um i i
i think people have blocked it out
they've heard it too much
it's too murky um you know it's really i
i honestly don't think that people are
actually that undecided in this election
so i'm not sure how much could really
affect it in the next couple of weeks
you think they've made their minds up
already yes i think if
pollsters are debating what percentage
are actually undecided from
six percent 14 to 25 percent but
i mean i don't understand how someone
can be an undecided voter
in the trump era and especially after
two years of a democratic primary now a
general election
so i think it's it's just so
um divisive right now you know
line signs or lawn signs are being
battled in america
suburbia uh it's it's you look at the
new york times bestseller list and it's
love trump hey trump love trump hey
trump
it's right down the middle and it will
come down to turnout
sarah what'd you make of uh i saw the
washington post and the nbc stuff and i
mean i know they both
have for years now been obsessed with
russia particularly in relationship to
uh donald trump
i was quite surprised
that what they were writing there were
very little facts to there were nothing
nothing on the record to substantiate
what they were claiming yeah someone
said if you read between the lines of
the
washington post story it actually
suggests that there is something here
that certainly that that our story is uh
uh
uh is not easily debunked which is funny
because it was the framing
versus what was left unsaid clashed that
way um
but i just want to go back briefly i do
think it could have
i don't know if it's demoralizing impact
or what the
precise nature of the impact would be
but there is the fact that um
you know democrats have been talking
about the trump team
quote-unquote colluding with a foreign
power for the past
three and a half four years and it's
there's this delicious irony in the fact
that robert mueller
his report definitively said there had
been no collusion between team trump
and the kremlin but that after all of
this
there's equality i don't know if it's
greek tragedy or comedy it
ends with us learning that you know the
the
mr norms mr returning us to the pre-2016
uh politics of of high ideals and high
standards
um you know his son worked for a
did kind of influence peddling in one of
the most corrupt countries in the world
ukraine
um so hey you know i mean do are most
people's minds made up but
yes but is there is does that does this
story cast doubt on
biden's pitch as mr norms mr standards
it does i think freddie uh
of course in a sense if you have a great
story
and someone tries to censor it i mean
it's the best thing that could happen
for the story when i when i was editor
of my university newspaper
uh way back just after guthenberg had
invented the pressings
um the one of the the student unions
banned one of my auditions it was the
highest selling edition
ever of the time when i was out of the
university newspaper and thanks to
facebook and twitter would it not be
true to say that more people now know
about this story than would ever have
otherwise known about it
undoubtedly and that's why with like
with all conspiracies it's
stupidity always far more than anything
sinister because
what they've done is backfired
spectacularly i think saurabh is right
this is a significant story it would
have been a big story
it would have been nothing like the
scale
that it is now if it had just been
allowed to rip through the internet so
and i think that's where it could have
an effect on the election because
everybody's sort of aware of the fact
now that hunter biden was was shady it
doesn't
quite influence their opinion of joe
biden maybe as much as it should
but i think what drives people crazy is
this idea that
our lives are so dominated by tech now
and
that tech has this tremendous power over
us and
and there is clearly a a significant
political bias within
big tech um and we've been told for a
long time we were told that
big tech that facebook cambridge
analytica was was what
got trump elected um and actually it
seems
that if there is a sinister bias going
on uh
it goes the other way well it is
interesting jacob that those who
claim that it was dirty works by
cambridge analytica and so on that
swung brexit to leave and swung 2016 to
trump
uh here you have a an upfront
example of big tech interfering in in
certain freedoms these same voices are
rather
quiet about it all at the moment they're
not saying very much at all
well they they've they've been squirming
for a while but i guess
my my query is what is the actual
obligation of these tech companies
that are private companies and can
essentially operate with impunity
and when you sign up whether it's on
twitter
or facebook you're operating by their
rules
and their their there are no rules of
the road
there's no congressional there's no law
saying that they have to operate in
specific ways
why can't they do whatever they please
well well i agree with
jacob to an extent but this brings us
back to the publishers versus
platforms debate and uh if these
companies are going to start
censoring and editing and effectively
making editorial decisions about
what's on their site uh then they become
much more responsible
legally as to what is on their sites
what they are publishing and if that's
going to be the case they're going to
find they have
an enormous amount of legal difficulty
down the road
jacob i guess that's that's fair but so
far they've managed to
elude and evade any responsibility
with facebook being perhaps the premier
example
and i'm not persuaded that that's going
to change
and that they are they've been twitter
has been more aggressive than the others
but as far as real legal action against
them i don't see it yet
so uh if i may jump in here and i
apologize for two things one is i have
to
leave early um and second one is i
i kept calling andrew i kept calling him
neil and it's
this is my millennial you're not the
first to do that there's a problem if
you have two names either of which could
be your first name
and also your twitter handle this is my
i i recognize you by af neil so i'm like
neil guy i apologize
but just to make my final point try to
take off is that
um look i think from the point of view
of conservatives i'm speaking with
a rubicon was crossed when when
uh they did this so blatantly so
systematically
some people talked about it as address
dress rehearsal for election day like
what would they do
um you know if if a dividend campaign is
unhappy with a certain right of center
voices
comments about what's happening in the
election could they suddenly
systematically shut us off
so there's a kind of libertarian
argument
uh that for long had a kind of
stranglehold
on the conservative mind when it comes
to these tech issues which is precisely
the one uh uh uh mentioned earlier which
is that
look they're private companies and they
can do whatever they want but
given that you know free speech really
lives or dies
on these platforms i mean i could go on
a street corner in manhattan and bang a
drum and say
hunter biden is corrupt but you know
very few people would hear me and i
would look like a nutter
but if you know if i
have a story that shows evidence but
then i can't you know vast
swats of the american public can't read
the story because it's been disappeared
then that alarms a lot of uh
conservatives so
people like senator josh hawley of
missouri
uh and others who have been pushing to
reform section 230
to say you either act like a platform
or we will treat you like a publisher
they now have the wind in their backs
because of this
and um you know chairman ajit pai of the
federal communications commission just
released a statement saying
that his uh regulatory body has
authority to properly
interpret what section 230 means
and that's very serious because their
their
that understanding could stay in place
even if biden gets elected in other
words when fcc
uh issues a ruling about what the law
really means and if it's been
misunderstood over the past few years
as the internet has evolved the fact of
the biden
presidential victory election victory
wouldn't
change this that that uh uh
uh interpretation unless we want to go
for a big like legal constitutional
battle about what regulatory agencies
can do and what authority they have
but i'll stop there and i apologize for
having to to leave early but thank you
all for
for having me sir mary from the new york
post thanks for joining us remaining
with us freddie gray sarah elliott and
jacob hilbroom
jacob let me come back to you again uh
there's always a legal uh element to
media media is the only industry
actually mentioned in the us
constitution
uh in the first amendment there's no
other industry
is mentioned in the constitution there
is always a legal dimension
to it and in a way
the the perhaps the way to look
particularly at facebook is as a
near monopoly uh it's it's the
it's the information age equivalent of
the robber barnes of the late 19th
century of the railways and the steel
of oil rockefeller and carnegie and all
the
the rest of it but of course a previous
republican president did something about
that uh
teddy roosevelt the republicans have
moaned and complained about it but
they've had the white house for four
years and i'm not aware that anything
has happened has it
it hasn't and interestingly i think
there
are voices on the liberal side that are
pushing for a crackdown
on the on what you what you rightly call
the monopoly
exercise by facebook that zucker mark
zuckerberg
is too powerful for his own good and for
the good of the united states
and i think there's probably it'll be
interesting to see i don't know how much
you know given all the domestic problems
the united states is experiencing right
now
i don't know how much of a push or how
much time congress will have
to go after these companies but
personally my own impulse would be yes
that the moment has arrived where you do
need strong reform and potential breakup
of these companies
because they have amassed a kind of
power that we probably have never seen
in the united states in its entire
history
interesting and not just in the united
states freddie just finished with you
on this am i right and thinking uh
maybe this may be going too far but that
facebook and twitter are really
beginning to regret what they did
that it's really backfired on them i
think i think they are and actually i do
feel
quite sorry for mark zuckerberg i mean
he's not an easy man
to pity but i do think you know he got
so much flack in 2016 because
uh the world he lives in blamed him for
trump it blamed him for brexit
you know angela merkel was caught sort
of berating him
uh for just allowing you know
politically unacceptable messaging on
his
on his platform and i think it's not
it's
actually facebook for a long time tried
to be the most free speech of the
major platforms uh and yet they always
get
the the blame there's they have they
have this enormous power but it's hard
to see how they could possibly regulate
it um and so i think that
this i'm not usually pro government uh
taking taking things over but i think
the idea that social media might become
a public utility in the end
is starting to look quite attractive
well then it would be regulated
monopoly utility would be regulated okay
let's move on
it's perhaps part of the agenda of a joe
biden administration i rather
what would it look like mr biden has
been in washington for almost five
decades we should have a clear idea of
what he stands for but
do we jacob let me come to to you
uh he's a mainstream
democrat uh his interests seem to have
been for a while more in foreign policy
than domestic affairs
there isn't uh there isn't a particular
there isn't a bidenism there isn't a
particular joe biden way
of looking at the american domestic
scene or
a raft of policies that you would
associate
with mr biden is that i think that
things could move very quickly if the
democrats win the senate
that that in that case
you would see a quite radical impulse
towards
overhauling the united states you would
see a rise in taxes
you'd see the repeal of the trump tax
cuts
you would see the justice department
would be remade
perhaps elizabeth warren would be the
attorney general
you would see a huge
push for an infrastructure bill aimed at
employing americans so i think if biden
win
if the democrats win the senate you
could also see the end of the filibuster
you could see a push to making dc in
puerto rico states
the impulse among progressives and
liberals is for a radical overhaul
of the american political system not
simply to restore the economy
but to enact fundamental reform that
incidentally would probably have the
effect
of entrenching a democratic majority for
decades
sarah elliot i can see if the democrats
take
the senate that they can do or they
they may attempt to do what jacob is is
saying that they could
end the filibuster by which you need 60
votes in certain
important uh pieces of legislation or
actions the senate is taking we could
give statehood to puerto rico
d.c that would certainly for the
foreseeable future mean four more
democratic senators
uh in in the senate and there is the
option not sure mr biden so keen on it
that he doesn't want to
upset his left of stacking the supreme
court fdr
attempted it in 37 it didn't really work
it backfired and
he pulled back though the court did
change um
some of its rulings after the threat so
it did kind of work
for fdr so i understand all that but if
i look at
what mr biden himself stands for if you
he he would reverse the tax cuts the the
the trump tax cuts but only for those
earning over 400 000 it would take the
top rate of tax back
to still under 40 percent where it was
with obama
and he plans to increase corporation tax
not to where it was under obama
somewhere in between trump and obama
they're pretty mainstream democratic tax
raises are they not
i disagree i mean first off
donald trump doubled the child tax
credit
went from six thousand dollars to twelve
thousand dollars that means you can
write off twelve thousand dollars off
your taxes
that's huge for a family of four or
family of
five six etc um also we had the most
uncompetitive corporate tax rate
in the western world uh before trump
came into office at 35 percent
he lowered it and it brought over half a
trillion dollars back to the u.s
immediately in the first six months
after the tax cuts
not much of which went into investment
it mainly went on share buybacks
and uh paying off debt and onto the onto
the corporate balance sheets
well there was no boost to business
investment
well i i would disagree because the
economy actually
has boomed to the best we've had on
record the lowest unemployment for
minorities
the lowest the biggest drop in the
poverty rate
the lowest it's been in over 50 years i
mean honestly the economy was the best
we'd had it on record
and i i don't know why you want to take
away those incentives
for small business for big business for
individuals and families by raising
taxes yes that's the typical democratic
thing to do
but it's incredibly uncompetitive and if
we and we're rebounding we're having a
v-shaped recovery in america right now
we've almost um gotten back over half of
our jobs 22 million jobs have
come back since covid lockdown so
i don't know why that's a good thing for
the american public
um and also you know if donald trump
were to come into office he
he potentially could make a lot of these
tax cuts permanent that we're sun
setting
and also cut capital gains even more
what's donald trump's plan to cut the
deficit
that's a very good question uh he is not
a deficit hawk he's not a fiscal
conservative
this is a concern for a lot of us in the
party
uh but they but the argument that people
like larry kudlow who's
his national economic advisor and was
omb
director under reagan would say is you
have to create
wealth you can keep these spending
programs and entitlements and i should
add that
our entitlement spending for social
security which is our state pension
uh is going to run out in four years we
have over a hundred
trillion dollars worth of unfunded
liabilities in the united states right
now
we do need a congress and a president to
take
this seriously this is not on the agenda
right now but i would suggest
to you that whether it's mr trump or mr
biden in the white house
uh at the inauguration come the 20th of
january
they are both gonna run unprecedented
peacetime
deficits throughout the 1920s
the 2020s uh that mr trump will do
because he'll cut even more taxes and
make some of these taxes
um permanent they're all unfunded
uh mr biden is going to raise over 10
years about 3 trillion
on taxes but he's going to spend 7
trillion so
he's going to raise it too i mean
frankly whether the deficit is caused by
more spending or unfunded tax cuts it's
a deficit is a deficit as a deficit
there's no difference well you know
the fiscal conservative in me agrees
with you
to a large extent it's over there's no
one fiscal conservative now you're all
running massive deficits but what i'll
say
is that the when you create wealth and
growth
um it's you know it's trickle-down
economics supply side reaganomics
whatever you want to call it
but reagan ran massive deficits reagan
man
ran massive deficits at one stage the
deficit
which for these days was 4.5 of gdp
his tax cuts never paid for themselves
that's never happened well it created a
lot of economic stimulus
that's true i understand that it was
deficit financed
that helped our economy beat the soviet
union and that that was the goal at the
time
even the scottish economy could beat the
soviet union i mean i don't think that
was a great
uh yardstick there just one final point
you talk about the corporation tax
you're the highest in the world you had
the highest rate in the world
35 percent or not the highest in the
world but one of them
in the western world of course um but
nobody paid it
the effective rate of corporation tax in
america
uh under obama was 18 because there were
so many
deductions nobody paid it and it
didn't make any difference in in the in
the end 18
was the average corporation tax in the
world you weren't uncompetitive
you just had a stupid high rate
well i you know i think the proof is in
the pudding when how the economy
responded and how much more foreign
earned investment
um and far and earned income came back
to america
i'm i i think it does matter and
it needed to change and i'm glad that it
did i haven't slowed you've had the
slowest
growth of of any recovery
since the second world war no that was
that was obama
after the great recession so will you
take them both together take obama and
mr trump average rate of growth under mr
trump has been under three percent
that's the slowest rate of growth of any
recovery
uh i i dispute that i'm sorry well
it's in the opposite budget management
you get it
there i mean we have we actually have um
gdp over two percent
we had you know three unemployment's the
lowest on record now i know the
unemployment is
i understand that and the black
unemployment uh
i got that i understand that too let me
bring freddie in here i mean the fact is
i i'm
very cognizant of what jacob said taking
the senate could be
a game changer because it allows some
fundamental changes not just an economic
policy that can go back and forward
i mean frankly the the difference
between mr biden and mr obama's policies
will be
pretty close to zero i would mention the
senate is a different matter
but matter but if you take his tax and
spend policies
they are pretty mainstream mr bidens
aren't they they're not
they're not way out he's he said he's
not having an aoc
uh green new deal he is raising half of
his spending will be paid for by
increases in taxes
it's it's a kind of fdr program with a
green tinge is it not
i agree i think i think bionomics is it
tries to sound
fdr like uh i don't think
uh that they've quite got there's as
much to understand they've quite got
their sums are making
any sense at all i mean seven trillion
is the
commitment to a pandemic response i
think all of the inspections of his
his programs suggest he won't be able to
raise more than four trillion
uh in tax i think it's going to be
unbelievable deficit i mean you know
you're right that trump and biden they
don't care
uh but i think biden cares even less
but i think i think biden actually isn't
that interested in domestic policy and
jacob will be
know much more about this than i but i i
mean
his real area of interest what he liked
doing as vice president was flying
around the world
um sewing up deals for his son hunter no
sorry so
showing up deals for uh america
and uh and he's he's very
he was there was a russian reset when he
came in that he sort of managed to ruin
in 2008 as vice president um
he's very good at going around the world
and sort of blundering
uh and i think that's what you'll have
you'll have a very foreign policy
focused
uh administration that will try to go
back to the
pre-trump settings in in in world
affairs that is
the iran deals back on
uh paris accords right back to the the
the atlantic alliance
the atlantic's alliance the
trans-pacific partnership will be back
on
uh it'll just be they'll just in terms
of foreign in terms of america in the
world
they'll just try and pretend the trump
thing never happened jacob i see you
smiling there
well i like the fact that freddy who
spent the past four years
wildly underestimating and soft-pedaling
trump's deficiencies is now exaggerating
bidens even before he's in office
okay i'll just let that hang on the wall
here i
perhaps the way to look at it is is this
jacob
you know what sarah and i were talking
about about corporation tax or deficits
and uh growth and does that
that's not what the american people are
talking about even thinking about
the real biden pitch is very
reminiscent of warren harding's pitch in
1920
which was a return to normalcy and
that came after the first world war the
spanish flew
there were race riots in america there
were arguments about immigration
as well in in 2019 1919 1920
and hardin just harding just said you're
exhausted with this guy wilson
he's exhausted himself he's not even
well he's got the spanish flu
which of course actually became a stroke
i'm going to bring you back to normalcy
in a sense isn't that that's basically
biden's pitch is it not
right exactly the question is i mean
americans have been reeling
since september 11th and one of the
reasons that trump got elected
was because of not just fatigue but
exhaustion
with the foreign policy with the neglect
of the heartland with the with the
endless wars abroad
all of that uh now there's trump fatigue
is there a normality that america can
return to
is it a normal nation i mean
my own suspicion is that by
biden will discover that america has
fundamentally changed and that he can't
just
rewind the clock back to some golden age
and of course that's what happened with
harding he got elected in a return to
normality
but of course america did not return to
normality it uh
it invented something called the roaring
twenties and uh
prohibition uh and and all the rest of
it
so all i literally it literally went on
a bender
it went on a bender which ended with the
biggest hangover of the 20th century um
with unforeseen consequences what do you
say to that sir
republican friends that i speak to and i
don't just mean the
the kind of the never trumpers or the
lincoln project type
uh republicans a lot of them they're not
huge trump fans but they just say we're
kind of exhausted
we're just you know do every morning we
wake up and
what's he done next what see we did next
what row are we getting into we seem to
have
made enemies of our friends the british
uh
the germans the french the italians and
he cozies up to people who really should
be our enemies the russians the chinese
erdogan and turkey the crown prince in
saudi arabia
enough already as they would say in new
york that's
that's quite a powerful argument is it
not it is but i
and i have friends like that too and we
go round and round in circles
and and this is the thing you jacob
makes a really good point
what is the new what is normal because
you can't go back to the way it was
before trump our relationship with china
is
completely different now everything is
out in the open
so are we going to elect a guy who
basically oversaw the selling of all of
our jobs overseas and also
you know got cash for access for his son
in china and
i i also i it's just he
back in may 2019 biden was saying
china's no competition for us
and then defense secretary uh gates said
you know joe biden he's a nice guy but
he's been on the wrong side of every
foreign policy issue of the last 20
years
so i i just i think joe would love to go
back to normal because that's what he
knows and you can't teach an old dog new
tricks you know he's
you know he's a 77 getting up there as
you're covered so rightly points out
this week
um he's going to find it very difficult
and he's also going to find a lot of
infighting from the progressive left of
his party
uh they're going to be pushing him and
pushing him and
and like you said we don't really know
what bidenism is
except that we know that his voting
record has gone increasingly left
throughout his 47 years in the u.s
senate
and he has changed his position on
everything whatever direction that the
democrats are going that's where he
changes so
you can't say that he's not going to be
a puppet for the left
especially the far left of his party
he's put one of the most liberal
senators on his ticket kamala harris
well freddie isn't the biden presidency
if it happens
will be a transition presidency and the
real battle for the soul of america may
be 2024
when the left could be much more
ascendant in the democrat
party and the republicans will have had
to
choose a new candidate there may be
elements of trump about that but it will
also be it will be more
a republican candidate than a trump
candidate and that
that's when the real battle will take
place is it not
i think almost certainly i mean the
question is how quick the transition
will be i mean will it be four years
or and this is an awkward point and
jacob's going to accuse me of
exaggerating biden's defects again but
we really do need to talk about
biden's mental health it's not just a
right-wing
canard that he's not all there he's he's
just not
every day he makes a very silly mistake
and it's not just because he's got a
speech impediment
he seems to have a kind of verbal
dyspraxia where he you know he
he said this week that he was running
for senate for the
for the senate and it's the second time
he's done that this year and you know
someone has said to him no it's the
presidency
that you that you're going for and he
says things like that a lot so
if if he's elected um it may well be a
kind of regency presidency where
everything's really being run by team
obama and possibly kamila harris an
increasing role for canada harris
and he is a sort of background figure
who a sort of figurehead a kind of
monarch
jacob i'll let you respond and then
we're going to move to our third and
final topic
i flatly disagree i think biden in
retrospect will be seen to have run a
brilliant
campaign probably one of the most
brilliant ones that we've seen in
decades
if he wins this presidency in a
landslide
he will have accomplished what no one
has accomplished
since ronald reagan barack obama did not
win by landslides
in recent decades the american
political system has been too evenly
divided for anyone to score a big
victory
as far as biden's mental acumen
i i think he's handled himself quite
well in the debate with trump
he did well in the town hall last night
i just don't see the problem
and also if you notice during the
campaign they've essentially shut down
kamala harris
it's biden in so far as he's campaigned
who has taken the leading role so i
don't know
i don't buy freddie's argument i don't
want to sound like a right-wing bore
about
that town hall last night but i thought
it was extraordinary he wasn't asked one
question
about hunter biden the major story that
everyone's talking about
and they didn't see fit to ask him a
question about it wasn't that surprising
jacob
have american journalists or broadcast
journalists lost their ability to ask
the tough questions
well no you saw they gunned after trump
now with stephanopoulos being soft
on uh biden maybe but biden also
freddie i just don't think that the
hunter biden story is all that
significant
or of much interest the american public
you may
think that it should be but it's not
okay i've been i've i've got no come
back to that other than a lot of people
if journalists don't ask questions about
it jacobs
i think the son of the son of the
president of the future president
former vice president being paid uh 50
million dollars
uh by a dodgy ukrainian mining company
when he had no relevant experience is
is quite a big story i mean i think and
was clearly providing access to his
father
um to to this ukrainian business
you see i think that the story i don't
put much stock
in the joe biden angle i think what's
shocking
is that hunter biden got i don't think
he got 50 million
but i still think it's emblematic of the
way that sleaze has become normalized
in washington dc yeah there was nothing
illegal about what he did
that's what that that will be the return
to normalcy
sarah i saw you agreeing not in your
head there
yeah i mean this is this is why trump
wants to drain the swamp
he's the swamp you know joe biden and
the way his family
have been leeches off of his power and
you see it with the emails with
in china and 850 here and we can set up
a holding company
i mean it's it's so gross and it's what
americans
absolutely hate about poland mr trump
hasn't drained the swamp he's created a
new swamp
of which his family are swamp kings and
queens
well i gotta tell you if you want to go
but like if you want to go back to
normalcy then it's going to be
all these kingpins and their family just
living off the large ass of public
service
so i think unlike the trump family
well i think they're entrepreneurs and
business people they'll go off and they
they'll go off and do other things or
maybe don jr will run
try to run for president in 2024 but uh
but they like making money the trump
family keep their crookery
in the private sector they have the
dignity to do that
yeah well you give me the you give me
the perfect
perfect segway there sarah into where
the
trump junior runs in 2024 to talk about
what will become of the republican party
just for
our final uh 10 15 minutes or so
let's assume this is by no means an
assumption we should take for granted
but let's assume that mr trump does lose
and that joe biden is the 46th president
of the united states
what happens to the republican party
in a sense donald trump launched a
successful hostile takeover of the
republican party for most of his life he
wasn't even a republican he was a
sort of new york democrat um but he
launched that hostile takeover
he has changed the nature of the
republican party in the process there's
no
i doubt about that the days of um the
old country club republicans seem to be
long
uh gone it's become increasingly a
blue-collar party
uh a more white party compared to george
bush or even
ronald reagan getting support from there
he certainly changed it so if he goes
what happens to the trump republican
party does it revert
does it build on that where does it go
what will happen
to the grand old party jacob
well this is the big question again it
depends
i know it depends on the election if the
if the republicans retain
the senate and trump loses then it is
merely a
repudiation of trump and trumpism
and the and the republicans will regroup
and they will return to some
harder core of reaganite foreign policy
and they will emphasize fiscal
responsibility and they will embrace
free trade
if the republicans lose the senate
and the presidency then the party's in
deep trouble
and it will have to it will be riven by
a
by a fight between pro-trump
and anti-trump factions and romney will
lead one camp
and tom cotton will be in the other one
ah senator cotton
in interest the the man that managed to
get the op-ed page editor of the new
york times fired
for his comp so how do you see it the
future of your party assuming
you it loses in on the third
it it never goes back to the way it was
you can forget about bush republicans
and i think you can actually think about
you can say goodbye to mitt romney
republicans to to some extent
um it it will take on the issue
of border security more so than it did
before thanks to president trump
it will also perhaps use um
tariffs and and trade wars um that seems
to be
more widely accepted now than it ever
did but
i say that the things that have been
solidified
in the republican party because of trump
that will not change
are definitely tax cuts and supply side
economics as well
as conservative textualist originalist
judges so supreme court judges that he's
appointed
that same tradition will continue to
carry through there will also be more
pro-life
more on the cultural issues and also on
the free speech issues
the i see the republican party really
embracing free speech
and uh you know conscience rights
freedom of religion and i see uh mike
pompeo
as a very good bridge between
the old republican party and the new one
he's been very
good not to steal the limelight from the
president overseas but he's also enacted
his agenda
very efficiently and effectively uh and
he's been a congressman he's been the
head of the cia
so uh he has a lot of respect from his
colleagues so i see someone like a
pompeo and nikki haley who served at the
u.n
as a possible future leader
christie gnome the governor of south
dakota who didn't
lock down her state during covet because
she didn't think it was necessary
she got a ton of flack for that and
she's coming out to be a real rising
star in the party
so uh keep your eyes on them jacob
what i don't understand is where the
votes come from
the the for a future republican party i
mean the current republican party is
living off
a declining base and it depends on a
differentially high
turnout of that base to win elections
that's what happened in 2016.
it's hoping to repeat that in 2020
though i think that's a
a stretch the base has been narrowed
down
and down to white blue-collar
rural small-town uh workers
uh people who live there the suburban
base of the republican party used to
have
seems to be going white suburban women
the polls suggest
our uh defeat have defected hugely the
hopes
of making inroads into the black vote
have barely got going
the hispanic vote which george bush got
a big chunk of
doesn't get now outside florida where
you have a non-mexican hispanic vote
there so
you get more cubans venezuelans
nicaraguans
and so on who've lived under communism
or socialism
i don't see where where you cannot live
forever off a
white blue collar base where do you go
they need to completely reinvent
themselves and they've been
you know trump managed to give one more
squeeze of the lemon
in 2016. but i would wager
that this time it's gone dry because
you know he governed as a hard right
conservative
if he had been a shrewd politician he
would have tacked
instantly to the middle and could have
demolished the democrats by embracing
infrastructure
instead he handed out massive tax cuts
mainly to plutocrats and
i agree with you on on his economic
record andrew
i mean i i the growth has been anemic
in the united states and that's another
reason we have these high deficits
the gop needs to become a modern
political party and right now it's
headed towards disaster freddie what's
your take on the future
of the gop well i think my prediction is
always more crazy not less
uh i think there are elements within the
republican party that becoming
incredibly paranoid um and
you know you see the sort of you now see
quite a lot of q anon you hear a lot
about q anon sort of radical conspiracy
theory that is now gripping
quite large chunks of the electorate um
at the same time though i think we have
to give trump a bit more credit perhaps
than we have on
how he has expanded the the working
class
the blue collar american vote he's made
people vote and get interested in
politics get involved in the culture
wars
that just weren't involved before and i
think we may actually see more of these
people voting
in 2020 than the current polls are
picking up on
where should the demographic base of the
republican party aim to expand itself
sarah
beyond the declining uh
base that it has at the moment i mean
even without
a lot more immigration america will
become
less white it is it is becoming
less socially conservative particularly
among
young people as as well almost
everywhere you look in every trend
that's taking place you we've seen how
virginia
used to be a red state is now a blue
state
georgia's always one of these it's about
to tilt because
the republicans have lost the suburbs of
atlanta
and it's increasingly dependent on the
rural vote we'll see if north carolina
tilts the same way because of the
arizona uh
you know maricopa county the most the
republican goldwater reagan used to rock
it
all these you know that was the heart of
um
western republicanism it looks like it
might go
for biden in this election it's very
close where do you get these votes now
well i actually disagree with jacob and
freddie saying that you know this
and and your assumption of this
shrinking base and everything because
i think donald trump has been the
disrupter the republican party has
needed to widen the base
and i see him growth among
african-americans
hispanics in a way that i haven't seen
well in my lifetime with the black vote
i'll be honest like
he i have never seen so many
african-americans
come out and support a gop candidate
before and i'm really interested in this
minority vote this cycle and seeing how
he expands
because he is expanding his support
among these demographics and and also i
think there are more
working-class votes that he can get and
is getting
for exa for instance the labor um
votes up in or the i should the late
the democratic party but they're the
labor unions
in northern minnesota i mean all the
mayors of northern minnesota who have
religiously been
democratic soldiers have come out and
endorsed trump for the first time
because they're getting jobs back to
their area they also hate the
destruction of the black lives matter
and the antifa riots that happened in
minneapolis
um so i actually think trump is widening
the base
for the republican parties definitely
changing the dynamics because
now the republicans look to be more like
the working-class party which has
historically been the democrats now the
democrats are
embracing the metropolitan cities and
and suburban areas you know more the
country club areas
so i i think it's really interesting how
it's reversing but
i don't think the african-americans are
going to be as loyal to democrats going
forward and the republicans definitely
need to widen their base with
with his uh minorities and hispanics and
uh new citizens to america
freddie do you agree with that i mean
there are a number of uh black figures
outside the mainstream largely
democratic black leadership who have
been vocal in favor of trump but all the
polling i see says
that he still gets less than 10 percent
of the black vote which is the historic
position of the republican party to get
less than that
outside of florida i don't see any great
move of hispanics to the republicans i
mean george bush
in 2000 got 38 percent of the hispanic
vote it was a peak
uh there i mean ronald reagan once told
me that uh
the hispanics were natural republicans
they just didn't yet just realize it
yeah uh and that that hasn't gone uh
so so well either i don't i can see the
opportunity there
uh to go for these votes if for our
mainstream republican i don't see mr
trump has done it
i don't think he has i think the the
black i mean we may be proved wrong on
election day but so far the black
outreach doesn't seem to have helped it
has
helped um to some extent with white
voters who worry about
being racist and if trump is seen to be
uh
embracing black voters and encouraging
black voters
it negates the idea that he's a racist i
mean on the hispanic vote
i think he is on calls to increase it
from 28 to i think 31 32
which is significant considering how big
that vote is and he's also growing among
asian americans which is a
very fast growing demographic in america
yes
uh but i think the big opportunity for
the republican party will be the fact
that
if you take once biden is sort of taken
out of the way taken out back
uh he you you are going to have a
democratic party that becomes
pretty radical uh far away from what
americans and a lot of minority
americans are comfortable with
um and if they move america in a
direction where it'll cause a revulsion
against
the party the democratic party then any
future republican party has a wide open
playing field
in years to come sarah
did i take it you thought mike pompeo
could be at least a transition
leader for the republicans that he could
take the party into
the 2024 election would that be i'm not
going to hold you two because i know a
lot can change
in four years but as you sit there now
was that what you were saying that that
would be
at the moment not a bad choice yes i i
think he's
he's a strong choice for that because he
does blend both worlds the pre-trump era
and the trump era
i also think nikki haley is also someone
who also blends that well she had been
governor of south carolina
um you know a big primary state he's
quite a mainstream republican though
isn't she yeah
yeah but she served very well as un
uh ambassador uh u.s ambassador to the
un
and so she and she left on her own terms
uh in a trump administration
so she left on a good high note so i
think those are two
ones to watch which is really
interesting because they're they're
foreign policy focused candidates
don't so much domestic uh and
but i think trump has been most
successful or
very successful on the international
stage as well so
but some of the things he's done there
haven't really been issues in this
election
his china policy seems to me is the new
normal now in washington that's the
consensus uh
um perhaps not with mr biden but senate
with a lot of democrats on the hill
uh and i it's been interesting that the
media hasn't really given them the
credit he should get for
what's happened in the middle east with
uh israel being recognized by the uae
and bahrain and i think very soon saudi
arabia and a man as well but
jake i'm going to come to you for the
final thing on the republican party and
it's this
in 1997 the british conservative party
was
pretty much destroyed by tony blair he
won the biggest majority
ever and it took to the year
2010 it took 13 years for the tories to
get themselves back to par but they did
it
and they've been in power for the past
10 years so
it took a while but they resurged mr
macron
in the 2017 french election
destroyed the gallus he destroyed the
socialist party too but he destroyed
the uh party the center-right party of
france
center-right party of france is still
nowhere still get is down to about nine
ten percent
in the polls the national front the sort
of hard-line
nativist party is the biggest uh
right-wing party in france now
so what where are the republicans going
to be are they going to learn from the
british conservatives
or are they going to end up in uh
in irrelevance like the french gallus
initially they'll follow the gallus path
my own prediction is we'll take
it'll take 12 years you'll have
two terms of biden contrary to what
everyone thinks in the new run again
yes wow if if he's a smashing success
there's no way that he won't run again
wow it's all lined up for him he's
coming yeah there's
going to be some amazing advances in
medicine in
the next four years
conrad anyway you're saying the 2020s
are a democratic decade that's what
you're telling us
that's that's my guess but you know
it'll it'll be
this happened to the democrats too i
mean it took them
uh several elections to
uh to regroup after jimmy carter lost
they it takes parties a long time
listen we're going to leave it there i
thank you all for joining it's been a
great discussion
uh and a discussion rather than an
ideological shouting match which is what
i see on so much american television
these days
i hope you'll all come back and join us
again as we build this little spectator
tv
uh franchise just a reminder if you want
to hear more from spectator journalists
the kind we've had in the program
subscribe to the spectators monthly
print edition
of the us and also at spectator dot u s
forward slash subscribe you get a
discount if you enter
tv code and also you get all of our
online
access which is constantly updated
because freddie
never sleeps he just keeps on posting
and posting
and posting sarah jacob
exactly a pleasure for you to join us
thanks to to our friends from the new
york post
thanks for you for watching but we'll
see you all next week
bye bye
you